gleich oberhalb der metropole la paz
beginnt eine verborgene welt
im vorort el alto haben sich die
hochland indigenen boliviens ihre
heimliche hauptstadt gebaut
elena ist bergsteigerin und braucht für
den gott des berges eine opfergabe zum
mitnehmen das gibt es in einem so
genannten hexen laden
[Musik]
von toten tierbabys bis zu kräutern und
tinkturen gibt es hier alles was den
göttern gefallen könnte elena bestellt
eine opfergabe die den berg besänftigen
soll schon das zusammenstellen der
zutaten kokablätter kräuter und figuren
aus zuckerguss ist ein religiöses ritual
wir bitten den agila den berg gott um
erlaubnis damit wir ohne schwierigkeiten
ohne probleme aufsteigen können und wir
alle den gipfel erreichen dazu bringen
wir den berg immer eine opfergabe
auf uns wirken die hexen läden wie ein
fenster in eine parallelwelt deren
kultur nie von uns europäern gestört
wurde in der die menschlichen probleme
vertraut sind die hilfsmittel aber
gänzlich andere wo der respekt vor der
natur göttern das maß der dinge ist
hinter den modernen fassaden in altus
stehen ganze straßenzüge im rauch der
opfer vor
diese kann man mieten um die alten
götter gnädig zu stimmen für was auch
immer einem auf dem herzen liegt
uralte rituale die auch die spanischen
missionare nie vertreiben konnten
hier schaut jesus immer in die andere
richtung
elena ist eine von 14 juillet ss cala
d'or das indigene frauen die berge
besteigen eine kleine revolution denn
das war in bolivien stets reine
männersache seit die colitis auf die
berge den sind sie für viele frauen zum
vorbild geworden
sie tragen den traditionellen rock und
gehen damit klettern das macht uns stolz
sie sind fleißige bolivianerin und mutig
das gilt aber auch für diese frau die
hier gemüse verkauft oft in der kälte in
der sonne um etwas zu erreichen kämpfen
wir frauen tag für tag das ist unser
kampf der kampf der frauen in den rücken
der zusammenhalt ist entscheidend frauen
werden in bolivien oft diskriminiert
deswegen ist es den solid as wichtig auf
den gipfeln der anden ein zeichen zu
setzen
feminismus zu fuß die bergschuhe sind
das einzige zugeständnis an die harschen
bedingungen ansonsten bleibt es bei der
tracht egal wie unpraktisch sie ist für
elena ist es wichtig dass ihre kleidung
der tradition entspricht damit niemand
sagen kann sie hätten geschummelt
ich trage hier einen unterrock ich habe
gerade vier lagen an
[Musik]
und 4
und das hier ist der rock den wir immer
an behalten weil wir ihn von klein auf
tragen wir sind sehr stolz darauf mit
unserem rücken klettern zu können
und deshalb wollen sie mit ihnen ganz
nach oben frei und selbstbestimmt vor
allem wenn sie tracht tragen werden
frauen in bolivien oft nicht ernst
genommen für viele gelten sie als
rückständig und gehören an den herd auch
elena und ihre freundin dem hochland
aufgewachsen sind wurden so erzogen
[Musik]
für sie galt ist beim tragen zu helfen
und zu kochen die gipfel aber waren tabu
unerreichbar das basislager stets
endstation
als wir mit dem klettern anfing wurden
wir stark diskriminiert
man sagte uns er wird der schnee
schmelzen als dass ihr klettert
denn bisher kletterten nur männer auf
die berge deshalb haben wir uns erst
recht das ziel gesetzt den gipfel zu
erreichen
die spitze zu erobern und es so den
männern zu zeigen
vor ein paar jahren haben sich die
ersten von ihnen einfach über die regeln
hinweggesetzt sind mit auf einen gipfel
gelaufen so fing alles an ihre ehemänner
akzeptieren es inzwischen und so
brauchen sie heute nur noch den segen
der pacha mama der mutter erde und von
et-china dem berg kommt und dafür haben
sie das opfer mitgebracht
[Musik]
um drei uhr morgens verlassen wir das
basislager im strengen frost der nacht
ist das eis des steilen gletschers über
den wir müssen am härtesten
bis zum morgengrauen halten wir nicht an
gleichmäßig wie ein uhrwerk arbeiten
sich die chollimas nach oben für uns
wird spätestens ab 5000 metern über dem
meer jeder schritt zur qual das gefühl
stadtluft nur leere zu atmen wird uns
bis zum gipfel begleiten
den schule das aber macht das nichts
nach sieben stunden sind wir oben
[Musik]
der gipfel auf 5.330 metern
der jubel galt dem werk gott der mal
wieder gnädig war
gnädig auch mit uns gringos das erste
lächeln des tages und die erschöpfte
erkenntnis dass wir hier oben wirklich
gar nichts zu melden haben
[Musik]
dies ist die welt der schulleiter des
kantons
für uns ist es sehr wichtig in unserer
tracht auf den gipfel zu kommen und
unsere röcke im wind flattern zu lassen
in den bergen sind wir glücklich
[Musik]
selbstbestimmt und frei wenigstens hier
oben eine kleine revolution
und doch noch weit entfernt vom alltag
vieler frauen unten im schatten der
gipfel